hello everyone my name is Rowan and
Donovan and I'm in the field working on
a story in northern Rwanda about
mountain gorillas hiking at 11,000 feet
is not easy we've so far gone up 3,000
feet since we started thicker stuff
about 11,500 feet now so we found the
Groves we have eyes on them but we're
gonna side of this ravine and there's
one up towards the skyline they're gonna
be tricky so during all tracking this
morning we just found two snares felix
is cutting the bamboo rods so that it
can't be used again
so really close to the grills we can
hear them chest pounding just over here
in the bushes and we can see this trail
that they used to go up the side of the
ravine okay we just found the gorillas
[Music]
well that's it for today folks
thanks again for following along with me
here in Rwanda I hope you enjoyed seeing
the mountain gorillas I know I did
[Music]